beyond the beauty of the american fall
there is a fight on in luzerne county
pennsylvania
this rust belt community was the
epicenter of trump's 2016 victory
and the battle to hold it or to reclaim
it is on
as biden supporters nudge towards their
man's rally
they're goaded by president trump's most
loyal
everyone here knows how important
winning this state is in propelling
their man to the white house
greg brannon was too young to vote last
time but he would have chosen mr trump
and that's not changed
here the enthusiasm gap is so high for
president trump that
even if biden announces up in the day
before you only see an
rv or two for biden but trump could say
i'm gonna be here in 45 minutes
and you get something like this it's a
huge enthusiasm gap
the legacy of 2016 endures here
crooked hillary is still a relevant cry
for supporters of the president
crooked jail you go home baby
but does adapting that for biden really
work
he seems to have a broader appeal here
[Music]
on the hill beyond john bon jovi is joe
biden's introduction
trump ran around saying he represents
the forgotten man a woman in this
country
i get it but then he got elected he
immediately forgot the forgotten man
but is that true do they really feel
he's forgotten them
in the county capital dr benjamin toll
is a local political scientist
four years on has anything changed i
mean has america been made great again
for these people
i'm not sure that's the question they
would ask i think the question that they
would ask is
do i feel better do i feel like my voice
is heard do i feel like someone gets me
and understands me
and even if the facts haven't changed
they feel heard
and so you know president trump is still
remarkably popular
among the people that voted for him in
2016. in many ways pennsylvania mirrors
the country yes its rust belt is dotted
with shuttered factories and derelict
chimneys but it's also a place
of affluent liberal suburbs and vast
swathes
of conservative countryside it reflects
a divided america
donald trump ended his weekend to the
northeast in new hampshire
we've done more in 47 months
than sleepy joe has done in 47 years and
i really mean it too
i really denise swing states his man of
the people image
seems to be holding strong mark stone
sky news in luzerne county pennsylvania